mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs le
débat que nous allons ouvrir ce soir est
un débat délicat difficile peut être le
plus délicat tunisie ont traité dans
cette série les dossiers de l'écran
c'est celui en effet de l'antisémitisme
l'antisémitisme faut-il le préciser et
bien c'est cette lutte parfois sourds
parfois ouvertement déclaré qu'ils se
manifestent un petit peu partout dans le
monde contre certains hommes pour une
seule et unique raison c'est qu'ils sont
juifs cette hostilité qui prend ses
racines très loin dans le passé se
manifeste encore de nos jours et même
dans notre pays puisque une enquête
assez récente de l'ifop indique que 20 %
de français sont antisémites déclaré
pour aborder ce problème nous avons
retenu un film le mur invisible un film
réalisé par ia kazan et dans leurs
relations dans le rôle principal est
interprété par grégory peck l'action de
ce film se situe quelques cinq ans après
la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est à dire aux alentours de 1950 1952
elle se situe aux états unis et puis
pour discuter de ce problème de
l'antisémitisme nous avons réuni dans ce
salon dans ce studio salon un certain
nombre de personnalités qui sont toutes
à des degrés divers ce ou à des titres
divers ce concernés par ce problème de
l'antisémitisme ces personnalités je
vais vous les présenter tout de suite de
manière que tout à l'heure vous puissiez
savoir qui vous vous adressez lorsque
vous ne téléphonera après le film par le
canal des épées vous nous posez toutes
les questions que vous voudrez bien
formés d'abord roger peyrefitte qui est
l'auteur de nombreux best-sellers est il
besoin de le rappeler la fin des
ambassades les clés de saint pierre les
fils de la lumière plus récemment les
américains et parmi ces best-sellers un
ouvrage important intitulé les juifs qui
explique ce soir sa présence parmi à
côté d'eux - elie wiesel qui est un
écrivain lui aussi un écrivain juif qui
a écrit les juifs du silence et le
mendiant de jérusalem
à côté de moi mais de l'autre côté
charles de chambrun ancien ministre du
commerce extérieur député de la lozère
est membre d'honneur du comité du mrap
le mrap je le précise le mouvement
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme et
pour la paix et à ce titre je t'en vas
vous avez est posé sur le bureau de
l'assemblée un projet de loi contre la
discrimination raciale
le perdre a beau fils le père dabo fils
est un orateur rien il est membre du
bureau d' amitié judéo-chrétienne et il
se préoccupe même at il précisé tout à
l'heure à titre personnel du
rapprochement de l'église catholique et
de l'église juive à côté de lui monsieur
le professeur giro agrégé de
l'université et sénateur de paris
monsieur le professeur giroud et
vice-président de la lica ali cas c'est
la ligue internationale contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme
le rabbin eisenberg qui présente chaque
semaine et puis les téléspectateurs
connaissent bien puisque il le voit
chaque semaine présenter l'émission
israélite à la télévision française à
côté de lui charles palant secrétaire
général du mrap je vous rappelle la
signification des initiales du mrap
mouvement contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme pour la paix monsieur
charles palant est également ancien
déporté de la résistance claude
jacquemart rédacteur en chef du
charivari
charivari a consacré l'an dernier deux
numéros aux juifs le premier numéro
était intitulé les juifs dans la france
contemporaine et le second numéro les
juifs et le monde contemporain à côté de
lui léon poliakov qui est l'auteur d'une
véritable somme une véritable somme
peut-on dire puisqu'elle se tient en
trois volumes d'une histoire d
antisémitisme et enfin roger ikor qui
est écrivain bien entendu tout le monde
le connaît et écrivain français mais qui
est aussi juif il a obtenu vous vous en
souvenez le prix goncourt en 55 pour les
hommes et les îles vierges plus
récemment de publier un ouvrage intitulé
peut-on être juif en france voilà
maintenant vous connaissez nos invités
vous pourrez tout à l'heure leur poser
des questions directement au cours du
débat et si vous voulez nous allons
regarder avec eux et avec vous tout de
suite notre film le mur invisible
poser des questions faire svp 11 11 sur
son cadran pour les téléspectateurs de
province qui sont reliés à l'automatique
ils doivent faire le 16 puis après la
tonalité musicale 2-1 puis svp 11 11
quant aux téléspectateurs de province
qui ne sont pas reliés automatique ils
doivent tout simplement demandé à
l'opératrice svp 11 11 a pas
merci le film que nous venons de voir le
mur invisible et bien l'action de ce
film se situe aux états unis bien sûr
aux alentours des années 50 52 environ
nous avons la chance d'avoir ici ce soir
elie wiesel elie wiesel qui est un
écrivain un écrivain juif et qui partage
son temps depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant entre les états unis et la
france alors c'est tout d'abord vers
vous et diviser le plus grande tournée
pour savoir si cette peinture vous
paraît outrés ou si elle reflète la
réalité des années 50 et ce qu'il en est
maintenant aux états unis
je n'ai pas connu l'amérique en 1950
je la connais depuis 1958 plus tôt
personnellement je n'ai pas vécu
l'antisémitisme en amérique j'ai jamais
eu quoi que ce soit à faire avec et
antisémites
ce très drôle les antisémites voix des
juifs partout
moi j'aimerais bien voir des antisémites
mais je ne les vois pas car ce n'est pas
à la mode aujourd'hui être antisémite
j'aimerais aussi posé une question svp
yat-il antisémite ici dans ce salon par
exemple les qui je pourrai discuter
j'espère intelligemment je sais pas je
ne crois pas parce que ce n'est pas
quelque chose qu'on fait aujourd'hui
c'est pas beau
cela dit je sais qu'il existe des
antisémites en amérique
parce que le cercle juif où j'évolue le
milieu juif auquel j'appartiens
consciemment et volontairement
on en parle beaucoup parfois un peu trop
est parfois passé
je sais qu'il ya même aujourd'hui des
clubs où les juifs n'ont pas le droit
d'inviter ya certaines maisons qui
exclut les juifs en effet omagh dit je
sais pas si c'est vrai que les juifs
riposte par une manière assez singulière
et peut-être assez amusante lorsqu'une
hôtel refuse un client juifs on achète
l'hôtel
peut acheter beaucoup d'hôtels peut-être
comme ça
il ya aussi
dans le sud dans le milieu raciste
beaucoup d' antisémite et on le sait du
coucou scan est antisémite
mais ce qui m'inquiète davantage
ce qu'on trouve des antisémites non
seulement dans le milieu de la droite
réactionnaire
traditionnel mais on en trouve aussi
dans les milieux d'où vient leur victime
on trouve même
chez les [ __ ] militants
lorsqu'il ya des émeutes [ __ ]
maintenant en amérique aura même manioc
cours chicago a détruit très souvent on
va sur les murs des choses écrites mort
aux juifs qui gisait au fond veut dire
moreau blanc mais pour une représentant
le blanc donc l'ennemi
alors je ne sais pas je crois qu'il n'ya
pas d'antisémitisme en amérique
l'amérique à d'autres problèmes un tas
de défauts et une telle tragédie en ce
moment mais ce n'est pas le problème
majeur
certainement pas pour l'amérique et même
pas tous les juifs américains
s'étant pas d'ailleurs que ce problème
de l'antisémite histoire
uniquement présent aux états unis angers
encore vous avez vous venez de publier
vous l'avez terminer l'année dernière en
67 je crois que c'était tout moment de
la guerre des six-jours d'ailleurs vous
avez écrit un livre qui s'intitule
peut-on être juif aujourd'hui poser une
question
en france je le disais tout à l'heure en
commençant cette émission une enquête
récente de l'ifop indique que 20 % des
français se déclare antisémite
ouvertement si vous en pensez
en ce qui concerne les pourcentages je
suis totalement je suis totalement
incapable de répondre bien entendu il
s'agit pas de chiffrer oui oui tout ce
que je lis le drian naturellement c'est
ce que j'ai pu vivre moi même alors ici
c'est une question terrible que vous me
posez finalement car dans le livre
auquel vous faites allusion
j' ai pu avouer et même craché
difficilement un certain nombre de
d'expérience que j'ai pu faire de la
question mais alors ici en présence de
centaines de milliers peut-être de
spectateurs
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus difficile
à dire en substance
voici comment le problème de
l'antisémitisme s'est posé à moi et
encore une fois très succinctement
avant la guerre le il n'y avait pas de
problème pour moi non qu'il n'y eut pas
l'antisémitisme naturellement avant la
guerre mais c'était un antisémitisme
ouverts déclaré lié à des questions des
prises de position politiques et
probablement par aveuglement d'ailleurs
je n'y ai l'un à l'autre les prises de
position politiques de l'extrême droite
l'action française par exemple avec cet
antisémitisme or pour moi c'était des
gens qui étaient attardé et la fois il
n'y avait pas de question autre que le
problème politique proprement dit je
n'ai jamais rencontré personnellement
une attaque directe d'abord parce que si
j'avais eu une attaque directe de me
faire traiter par exemple de sale juif
se seraient partis immédiatement la
paire de claques aurait immédiatement
gicler qu'est ce qui se serait passé à
ce moment là bas ma foi jean sérien où
je suis le plus fort chute plus faibles
c'est une question évidemment très
simple cela ce qui se pose le véritable
problème qui se pose celui que je ne
voyais pas avant la guerre
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de décrire dans
mon bouquin en appelant cela la pression
de radiation
pression de radiation c'est un terme
scientifique que je m'excuse utilisé
peut-être de travers mais enfin en
substance ça veut dire à peu près ceci
n'est ce pas la lumière
agi de manière extrêmement fine
extrêmement subtile dans le cosmos sur
les particules infime de matière cette
pression qu'on appelle pression de
radiation est à peu près insensible et
pourtant comme elle agit longuement et
sur des masses énormes elle fini par
concentrer la matière de telle manière
que les étoiles elle même en est d'après
les dernières théories je crois et bien
ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'antisémitisme
redoutable selon moi ce n'est pas
l'antisémitisme ouvert je rejoins un peu
ce que disait tout de suite wiesel et
certaines scènes du film également c'est
l'antisémitisme de radiation cette
espèce de halo qui vous entoure et
contre lequel vous êtes pratiquement
désarmés on parle par exemple de
plaisanteries
sur les juifs enfin les histoires juives
classiques dont
6,2 juifs sont face à face et se
racontent des histoires juives
naturellement il n'y a pas de problème
mais si le bonhomme qui est en face de
moi me raconte une histoire juive
comment puis-je savoir naturellement 6
est dirigée contre moi à supposer qu'ils
sachent qui je suis ou bien si c'est une
plaisanterie anonymes ou bien si c'est
une plaisanterie qui ne l'est pas et
bien tout cela agit sous forme de
pression lente et vous refoule
progressivement voilà ce que je ne
voyais pas je crois avant la guerre pour
l'or parce que j'étais trop jeune et
alors j'ai eu cette expérience que j'ai
compté rapidement sommairement et avec
embarras dans mon bouquin l'expérience
d'un camp d'officiers en allemagne
cela raconte encore une fois très
brièvement et avec le plus de simplicité
que je puis dire pour ces choses là il
faut être simple lorsque je suis arrivé
dans mon au flag
j'ai décidé sur un plan purement logique
de raisonnement logique ça ne regardait
absolument pas les allemands si j'étais
juif ou non et à la demande qui était
fait sur la feuille d'entrée la feuille
d'inscription religion j'ai répondu ce
qui était des tirs la stricte vérité en
réalité mais sur un tout autre plan pas
de religion bien
sam entraîné à un certain nombre
d'autres choses à l'égard de mes propres
camarades de captivité c'est là que la
question a commencé ses portes à se
poser car je me trouvais dans au début
dans une chambre de 48 officiers
j'ai eu très vite des amis très proches
que j'ai d'ailleurs conservé qu'ils
savaient parfaitement qui j'étais
mais toujours sur la même lancée de ce
camouflage volontaires
étant donné les racontars qui pouvait
traîner dans le camp et qui arrivait
toujours aux oreilles des allemands j'ai
décidé également de ne pas crier sur les
toits que j'étais juif à vrai dire vous
comprenez le problème ici est très
difficile à éclairer parce que comment
voulez vous que je fasse à - d'arborer
l'étoile jaune sur - poitrine comment
voulez vous que je dis je suis je suis
pas juive de religion comme le bonhomme
du film comme david goldman du film de
nationalité je suis français bon ben
j'étais exactement ce que j'étais au
milieu de mes camarades et cette
pression s'est peu à peu renforcées
jusqu'à
éclater et non pas directement contre
moi mais dans des conversations
disons marginal vous comprenez les 48
hommes dans une chambre ça parle de tout
et ça parle de rien et bien dans un coin
c'est une conversation sur telle mesure
prise par vichy comme quoi il était
interdit par exemple aux juifs de
s'asseoir sur des bancs de l'hém en
particulier et cetera alors les gens qui
étaient là commentait est-ce que c'était
dirigé contre moi ce que ça l'était pas
je n'en sais rien il ya eu des tas
d'histoires derrière cela mes amis ont
pris parti au bout d'un certain temps
enfin bref c'est à la suite de cela que
j'ai fait vraiment à travers mes
camarades de captivité de misère car en
face c'était pas drôle en offline et
bien c'est à travers cela que j'ai fait
réellement la connaissance de
l'antisémitisme ouvert la suite de quoi
rentrer en france en 45 j'ai décrété une
fois pour toutes que comment voulez vous
que je fasse et bages arborerait
l'étiquette juif et d'une certaine
manière en écrivant mon bouquin les fils
d'avant j'ai arbres et effectivement
cette équipe cette étiquette juillet
logiquement je devrais me tourner vers
vous maintenant parce que je ap les
téléspectateurs que vous êtes rédacteur
en chef du charivari que ce mensuel ce
journal a consacré l'année dernière deux
articles de numéros spéciaux de numéro
plutôt pas spéciaux de numéro deux dans
sa collection
aux juifs le premier était consacré aux
juifs dans la france contemporaine et le
second où juifs dans le monde entier
bien est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
la vision de roger ikor écoutez je veux
dire ceci c'est que n'étant pas juif
moi-même j'ai évidemment une vision
totalement différente et je n'ai pas les
expériences qu'ont pu faire elie wiesel
records alors c'est respectives
concernant ce film je voudrais dire ceci
c'est que il met en scène en quelque
sorte il dépeint sous l appellerai
l'antisémitisme de peau et qui me paraît
être une forme particulièrement vulgaire
et méprisable le dis carrément de
racisme car en fait ce film ne présente
qu'un aspect d'un problème quel problème
général du racisme ici il s'agit des
juifs mais on aurait très bien pu faire
un film du même genre avec avec les
[ __ ] ou avec je ne sais pas les
algériens les nord africains bon il
s'agit des justes mais non il s'agit
d'un aspect partielle d'un problème
beaucoup plus générales comme tel ce
film je crois pas je ne crois pas qu'il
aborde le fond du problème si vous
voulez une prime semble assez
superficiel si vous voulez on pourrait y
revenir dans le cours de la conversation
mais si vous voulez ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que vous avez consacré vous et vos
collaborateurs une enquête extrêmement
large confondit à ce problème des juifs
et d'antisémitisme par la même occasion
si vous voulez les sons abandonnant un
petit peu le film est votre étude est
peut-être exact mais revenons au
problème
actuel contemporain si vous voulez est
ce que vous estimez que l'antisémitisme
ce produit de la manière dont la l'apn
d'alors roger ikor c'est extrêmement
difficile a dit en ce qui concerne
l'antisémitisme en france qu'il existe
sous la forme d'une enseigne et
antisémitisme de peau je le crois dans
quelles proportions
c'est extrêmement difficile à dire
l'ifop avait réalisé une enquête à ce
sujet vont pas en accepter les chiffres
ne sais pas dans quelle mesure fait
effectivement
la réalité
on peut dire quand même une chose si
vous voulez
des paroles de roger ikor c'est que il a
une impression d'étouffement de sorte
que les sauts qu'il est plus dangereux
de se heurter à ce sentiment d'
antisémitisme larvé
insaisissable que local antisémitisme
ouvert qu'il a connue autrefois si la ti
sémitisme est tombée aujourd'hui sous
cette forme et tout fait en quelque
sorte et insaisissable ça tient
peut-être au fait simplement que que les
lois les lois françaises interdisent le
nom de l'anti sémitisme ouvert il existe
un décret-loi marchandeau qui a été
premier lui avant la guerre qui a été
ensuite
aboli par vichy qui a été remis en
application après les hostilités donc à
la libération qui est toujours en
vigueur et qui interdit les cols
l'antisémitisme sous la forme ouverte
sauf qu'un colloque plus que n'a pu
connaître autrefois donc autant de
l'action française donc ne subsiste plus
effectivement que cette forme larvée que
cette forme souterraines alors savoir si
les plus dangereuses qu'est-ce que tu l
antisémitisme autrefois je n'en sais
rien sam à connaître l'opinion de roger
peyrefitte roger peyrefitte et bien
l'écrivain tout le monde connaît mais il
a écrit un livre très important ils
s'appellent les juifs et un livre qui a
été fort controversé lors de sa parution
quand même donné lieu à un procès je
voudrais connaître votre opinion sur ce
problème
j'ai découvert comme bien des français
le l'antisémitisme par la guerre avant
la guerre je ne savais même pas ce
verset et pourtant il y en avait déjà
une de ses formes que mélangez-y corps
appelées larvée puisque j'appartenais
n'étant pas écrivain ce moment-là à un
ogre carrière diplômé diplomatiques et
dans laquelle il était admis de ne pas
recevoir les juifs par conséquent nous
avions tous l'air d'admettre sa très
naturellement et comme je les dis
peut-être avec un
l'intention de faire sourire ceux à qui
je le disais que les copies les écrits
et ses les diplomates se rattraper en
époux centre juif ainsi il y avait une
compensation qui se faisait parler
mariage et qui faisait qu'on ne peut pas
dire que les juifs étaient vraiment
exclu de la carrière mais enfin cela ne
posait pas de problème d'ailleurs
quelques juifs de noms très rares à vrai
dire deux ou trois avaient réussi déjà
entré dans la carrière
avait des places même importante voilà
ce que je savais de l'antisémitisme
avant les hostilités à la guerre nous
avons découvert l'antisémitisme n'ont
pas français mais il faut bien le
rappeler allemand qui était imposé au
gouvernement de vichy et dont nous avons
tous ses téléspectateurs
d'abord incrédule parce qu'on ne savait
pas du tout ce que l'on faisait de ses
juifs que nous voyons arrêté à paris et
naturellement elle à libération nous
avons su des horreurs qui s'était passé
et quand la carrière d'écrivain ayant
commencé à ce moment là j'ai toujours
pas je suis dit d'ores et déjà que
j'écrirai un livre sur les juifs puisque
une sorte de fresque de la société
contemporaine se dessinait déjà sous ma
plume et que cela devait sans doute en
être une des parties de plus importante
lorsque j'ai écrit ce livre qui a été en
effet controversé qui a donné un procès
malheureux pour ce qu'ils ont engagées
car ils ont renoncé à le poursuivre
d'ailleurs j'ai prétendu apporté à la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme
un argument majeur qui n'a pas été
semble-t-il bien compris alors par où de
nombreux électeurs de nombreux lecteurs
français ce procès ayant empoisonné
l'atmosphère en france mais j'ai été
très heureux de voir que la traduction
américaine de ce livre qui a été qui a
été publié il ya quelques mois à nous
provoquer des artic infiniment plus
compréhensif comme par hasard en
amérique ce pays que j'ai découvert
l'année dernière et dont j'ai admiré
tendu khalip telle intelligence et
d'abord la manière dont il a réglé le
problème juif et un journaliste je crois
dans le newsweek de ces grandes revues
indique la rics que c'était une d1 des
arguments les plus intelligents jeu mais
qu de rapporter ce terme trop flatteur
compte dans la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme c'est la découverte des
juifs a connu cette découverte est
équivalente à peu près à celle de
l'offre de christophe colomb par
parenthèse christophe colomb lui-même
était juif cette découverte a consisté
consistait à dresser une liste que je
n'ai pas prétendu vous le pensez bien à
faire exhaustive mais dont je veux lui
donner une idée de eux des noms qui de
tous les gens qui ne se croyait pas du
tout juif et qui n'étaient jamais qui
n'avait jamais été considéré comme juif
et qu'il y avait des chances ou des
risques de l'être à partir de ce moment
là le problème de la minorité de
l'éternel minorité juive avait des
champs à devenir brusquement un problème
de majorité lorsqu'on rappelle qu'il ya
eu des juifs français dans la liste des
jupes de paris de 12 196 qui s'appelait
durant il n'est donc plus question à ce
moment là ni de juifs puissent les
polyakov eisenberg ikor où tous les non
juifs que nous avons et qui d'ailleurs
sont beaucoup sentent ils illustrent cet
argument qui a été si mal interprétés
par certains critiques français en
prétendant que chalon j'ai ainsi des
listes de proscription comme si les
horreurs du nazisme ne pouvait jamais
renaître cet argument est pour ainsi
dire enfantin encore fallait-il y penser
bien pour ça que je pars d'oeuvre de
christophe colomb et 6 je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait des risques de retour de
l'antisémitisme en france les fameux 20
% que les d'antisémite prétendu que les
relèvent les statistiques ne représente
à mes yeux que les éternels mécontents
ce sont ceux qui protestent peut-être
contre le fait que les commerçants juifs
sont plus habiles que leurs concurrents
chrétiens que les grandes banques juifs
ont le meilleur à faire que que les que
les banques qui ne le sont pas etc
n'est-ce pas tout cela n'a pas une
grande importance est le problème ainsi
ce ne n'est pas attentatoire ni
périlleux pour les juifs je faisais
allusion à l'amérique où je disais que
je m'étais réjoui de voir se régler le
problème juif et d'ailleurs dont j'ai
admiré la civilisation en ajoutant que
cette civilisation en été sans doute si
grande que parce que les juifs avaient
eu la possibilité dans ce pays là pour
la première fois d'être entièrement
eux-mêmes ainsi
le seul fait d'être devenu comme je le
suis l'admirateur situation américaine
règle bien la question de des intentions
que je pouvais à barran écrivant ce
livre intitulé les juifs roger
peyrefitte si vous le permettez je
voudrais prendre l'avis de nos invités
pour savoir s'ils partagent vos opinions
et si les arguments que vous avez si
brillamment développés sont partagées
par l'assemblée ici je suis pas l'homme
chez polyakov doit effectivement c'est
une oeuvre de colons mais c'est un oeuf
de colomb universel je veux dire par là
un calcul très simple montre que ce
qu'un de nous si on remonte au temps de
saint louis à quelque chose comme 10
millions dans cette alors en ce sens si
vous voulez nous sommes tous suivent
nous sommes tous normand nous sommes
tous sereins nous sommes tous nés et
ainsi de suite
si vous voulez pour former ma question
peut plus directement si vous voulez
lire ici parmi eux un certain nombre
personnalité jouis est-ce que si vous
voulez me permettre est-ce que les
arguments qui viennent d'être
développées par roger peyrefitte est ce
que savent que cela vous paraît être des
arguments
anti sémite je me permets de poser cette
question parce que vous savez qu'elle
vous a été que ça vous a été reprochée
donc je voudrais je voulais qu'on
procède ici à d'expérience en vase clos
disputer
le ballon sur ballon je le précise que
vous êtes secrétaire général du bras le
mrap étant le mouvement contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme pour la poêle je
crois monsieur jérôme qu'on ne peut
répondre à votre question que si on la
situe dans un contexte
vous avez évoqué un sondage qui a été
fait il ya maintenant près de deux
heures fait cela
je retiendrai de ce sondage
deux choses
que s'il est vrai que 19 à 20% des
français
avouent leur antipathie voire leur
hostilité à l'égard des juifs
cela signifie également que 80 % des
français
se déclarent en dehors de ses sentiments
ne souscrivent pas ni à cette hostilité
ni à cette antipathie
seulement 20% des français
cela représente 10 millions de nos
compatriotes
1%
a même reconnu
qu'après tout le massacre de six
millions de juifs par les nazis
pouvait avoir été une mesure salutaire
1%
cela veut dire cinq cent mille de nos
compatriotes
et bien comment peut-on rester
indifférent devant ces chiffres
bien sûr
il y à
l'antisémitisme des vieux préjugés
et on peut en discuter
il y a les séquelles voyez vous
permettait de les interrompre je vous ai
posé une question pays précise bien
voulu prendre parole j repos là je vous
ai dit comme pour leur répondre que dans
un certain combien extraits il y as
qu'il subsiste
de la propagande hitlérienne et vichyste
du temps de l'occupation
il y a que dans le malheur les hommes et
parfois des nations
se réinstaller à en chercher un bouc
émissaire quelqu'un que l'on peut
accuser de tous les malheurs
et bien c'est dans ce contexte qu'il
faut situer ce procédé
qui consiste
à dresser
par rapport à certaines professions à
certaines activités nationales
la liste des juifs
qui semble avoir réussi dans telle
profession ou dans quelle branche
d'activité
et la mise en exergue de telles listes
livrer au public à grand renfort de
propagande
contient en elle même
la suggestion d'une sorte de mainmise
ward un complot
et pour peu
que cela soit livré à un public en proie
des préoccupations qui par ailleurs
lit tous les matins
dans son journal quotidien
que
on parle parfois du juif joanovici comme
on dit le français halimi
on parle de l'algérien de banlieue qui
violent nos filles mais on parle du
français mimoun voilà donc un contexte
dans lequel il faut apprécier ce que
signifie la réception par le public de
tels ouvrages
je perds fuite a bien voulu dire tout à
l'heure qu'il était remonté jusqu'au
12ème siècle
je l'en félicite
sur le strict plan professionnel mais
nous sommes encore trop proche de
l'époque où il suffisait de remonter
jusqu'à la seconde génération pour aller
à och chute voilà comment je voulais
répondre à votre question
je vais c'est une très noble réponse
mais je crois que je répondrais aussi a
réussi à me supporter qui ne me semble
pas nécessaire de cacher le la réussite
des juifs dans certains domaines et je
me flatte au contraire pour mon pour
avoir bien montrer tout ce dont il était
capable par leur intelligence leur
travail l'orginie dans tous les domaines
d'avoir ajouté à la liste des juifs
comme soupçonnait pas ne serait ce qu un
nom comme celui de mozart il ne s'en
avec ainsi il est difficile d'aimer la
musique est d'être antisémite à partir
d'autres à partir de cela car on parlait
toujours de mendelssohn n'est ce pas et
de génie peut-être vina vous permettre
l'observation dessus comme militant
antiraciste
j'ai d'abord appris
que dans la généralisation que ce soit
pour rejeter ou pour flatter il y avait
déjà le commencement du racisme vous
citez vous pouvez citer de nombreux
juifs qui ont réussi
leur réussite
comme leurs échecs éventuellement ne
devrait pas selon moi
peser sur l'ensemble d'une communauté à
qui on peut trouver des traits communs
entre lesquels entre les membres de
laquelle il existe sans doute des
affinités
mais je ne vois pas en quoi vous
prétendez contribué à démystifier
l'antisémitisme à partir du moment où
vous entrez dans le jeu de cette
généralisation qui a toujours été celle
des racistes
je n'accepte pas ces compliments
collectif que vous me faites je ne veux
pas que rejaillissent sur moi qui ne
suis qu'un juif comme beaucoup d'autres
ni la gloire de mozart ni lait ni les
selles ratait d'un certain nombre
d'autres de mes congénères dont je ne
suis pas plus responsables se refuse à
croire qu'il ya quelque chose car
finalement je me suis senti un peu visé
par les propos de monsieur talent
lorsqu'il a dénonce
les gens qui se livrent des numérations
n'est ce pas des juifs qui ont réussi se
trouve que nous avons fait précisément
ce genre de travail il y a un an dans le
charivari qui était consacrée aux juifs
dans la france contemporaine et tout ce
cette revue ce numéro a été réalisé sans
aucune intention antisémite
ce qui n'a pas d'ailleurs été la vie tu
aimeras paix qui nous a fait un procès
bon ce que je voulais dire simplement à
ce propos c'est que nous ne sommes pas
seuls à faire ce travail puisqu'il vient
de sortir un guide juives de france qui
est réalisé par des juifs et on trouve
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire la
liste de tous les juifs que réussit tout
soit dans la littérature dans la
cinématique ra et c'est cette alchimie
un charivari juifs tuent vous voulez
c'est exactement la même chose alors ce
que vous pour ce que vous reprochez
alain vous pouvez difficilement n'est
pas le reprocher je ne connais pas
l'oeuvre dont vous parlez j'ai appris
hier celui des livres pas non plus de
brevet d'antiracisme
c'est alors le grand rabbin kaplan cet
ouvrage satisfait chiffre tout à fait le
jeu à mon tour à tour sur roger
peyrefitte donc je soupçonne vos
intentions car que je suis persuadé que
votre livre et vous même êtes en
l'espèce pavé de bonnes intentions
vous avez voulu vous connaissez comment
vous savez comment le canard enchaîné je
crois résumer votre livre tout le monde
est juive sauf mendès france
ça signifie n'est ce pas que pour vous
lance ça signifie que pour vous du moins
votre livre peut être interprété de
telle manière que l'ensemble du pays et
comme on dit dans les milieux anti
sémites en juive et et cela relève par
conséquent selon moi de ce contexte
global auquel faisait allusion monsieur
pas lent mais que je désigne et moi
aussi tout à l'heure sous le terme de
pression de radiation
je veux dire qu'à partir du moment où on
concentre
une étude sur la place du juif à ce
moment là on l'isolent et cela en soi
seul et dangereux cela dit j'ajoute que
personnellement je crois absolument
indispensable de projeter la lune hier
sur les êtres et sur les choses et sur
les fêtes car je crois profondément je
pense qu'ici je vous rejoins tout de
même en profondeur je crois profondément
à la seule une médication valable contre
l'antisémitisme et la lumière
c'était un peu est ce qu'on peut se
pencher un instant je pense s'avancer
polyakov puisque vous avez commis une
somme importante en trois volumes sur
l'histoire de l'antisémitisme est sûre
on peut se pencher rapidement si vous
voulez sur les causes principales de cet
antisémitisme
et bien c'est une histoire fort longue
mais qui n'est pas internet et que je
sers et d'exposer d'une manière bien
brève il est certain que dans
l'antiquité ou déjà bien avant l'ère
chrétienne il existait une importante 10
patients juive il n'y avait pas
d'antisémitisme dans l'empiré romain la
position des juifs étaient bonnes et le
judaïsme n'était considérée comme une
religion honorable de même
il y a eu depuis des temps très reculés
des colonies juives dans l'extrême
orient en inde où elle existe encore et
ainsi nous existait encore il ya peu de
temps et là non plus les juifs n'ont
fait que couler non fait colonie des
fleuves donc ni de fleuves de sang c'est
dire que
l'antisémitisme
est un phénomène de la civilisation
occidentale
et ceux qui souhaitent se passe et c'est
si que d'après la conception de l'église
médiévale
les juifs sont le peuple déicide
coupable du plus grand crime de tous les
temps et en même temps ils sont le
peuple témoin qui doit attester par son
abaissement même dans la vérité du
christianisme
donc ils sont soumis à un statut un
femme ans ils doivent porter la ruelle
ils n'ont pas le droit de posséder la
terre ils sont avancés de presque de la
plupart de métiers puisque on les
accepte pas dans les corporations
chrétienne et on ne le laisse comme
possibilité que les métiers informant
et notamment le prêt à intérêt pourquoi
le prêt à intérêt parce que d'après le
construction du temps le chrétien qui
prêtent de l'argent à intérêt fort fait
son salut éternel donc il vaut mieux que
ce soit le juif qui le fasse puisque les
données de toute manière
dans ces conditions les juifs au moyen
âge dans la mesure où ils ont pu suivre
ce sont en partie spécialisée dans les
activités financières
donc dans ces conditions étant donné ce
qu'on appelait l'enseignement du mépris
par rapport aux juifs de l'église
le populaire les a hissés et en leur
qualité de plater d'argent et en leur
qualité de déicide et il s'était entouré
d'un halo de légende
il était censé dégager une odeur
spéciale qui se posaient à l'odeur de
sainteté il était censé tuer les petits
enfants chrétiens profaner les estives
quand il y avait une épidémie c'est que
les juifs avaient empoisonné les puits
ils étaient donc les boucs émissaires
par excellence
et c'est dans ces conditions que
les juifs ont éteint entouré d'un halo
de suspicion et de haine qui d'une
certaine manière et malgré tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis la laïcisation
l'émancipation a survécu presque jusqu'à
nos jours est la meilleure preuve c'est
ce conte la légende des sages de sion un
des meilleurs outils la propagande dit
l'indien
c'est une version à peine laïcisé du
mythe des juifs qui veulent la position
de la chrétienneté
ils étaient les juifs étaient censés
former une société secrète quittera mais
la tradition de tous les chrétiens et
qui ambitionnait le pouvoir mondial
et cette légende qui
a énormément celui à la propagande
hitlérienne a encore réparé eu
il ya une quinzaine d'années
la plupart doit s'en souvenir alors ce
que peu avant la poire mort de staline
ont lancé les crocs du complot sioniste
impérialiste des blouses blanches qui
veulent empoisonné les chefs du
communisme et ainsi de suite
sur la tournée vers le perdre a beau
fils qui est orateurs dont qui est bien
voulu assister en 7 et émissions en
effet mon père vous êtes l'un des
artisans du rapprochement
actuel assez récent nous le dira de
l'église catholique et l'église juive et
je polyakov a parlé de de la longue
légende qui faisaient considérer les
juifs comme des déicide et qui a été je
crois si je ne dis pas de bêtises
entretenu pendant très très longtemps
pendant de très longues années plus très
longs siècles par les miss cathodique
en effet le rapprochement est assez
récent comme monsieur polyakov comme
vous-même l'avait dit très justement
je crois que les faits cités par
monsieur poliakov sont indéniables je
crois qu'il n'ya pas d'historiens
sérieux qu'ils puissent ne pas les
reconnaître
quelle que soit sa religion
je pense que les historiens catholique
des théologiens ont depuis un certain
temps reconnu la parfaite vérité de ce
te ce description seulement peut-être
pourrait-on éclairé l'analyse de
monsieur poliakov en faisant remarquer
que derrière l'antisémitisme tel qu'il
était décrit tout à l'heure où sa forme
médiévale ou si vous voulez plus haut
que cet antisémitisme il y a l'anti
judaïsme de la rupture
et je serais tenté de mettre une
différence assez profonde entre un anti
judaïsme qui a des causes dont la
grandeur n'échappe à personne croyant ou
incroyant
ce schisme sera ordinaire survenue à
l'intérieur de la communauté juifs qui
fait que des juifs se sont séparés et
que les chrétiens sont des juifs
chrétiens se sont par héritage
donc entre cet antijudaïsme née de la
rupture les contaminations qu'il a
supporté par la suite
contamination de la cité chrétienne
qui reprend à son compte
l'assimilation de la religion avec la
cité comme il en était dans le paganisme
car la chrétienté au fond c'est une une
reviviscence de la cité païenne
imprégné de religion et à partir du
19ème siècle lorsque la notion de
chrétienté n'est plus qu'un regret
entretenu d'ailleurs
ce qui fait que les pères
assomptionnistes de la croix ont fait
presque sans le vouloir un sort aux
protocoles de sion ouais voilà quelques
manigances antisémite mais par
nationalisme
le par pour les choix qu'on avait fait
dans l' affaire dreyfus donc un autre
élément vient contaminer l'antijudaïsme
c'est cet antisémitisme qui venue du
nationalisme ou qui est venue du racisme
et je dirais en somme que je reconnais
qu'il y à un antijudaïsme chrétien qu'il
a fait du mal et que nous espérons le
voir cesser mais je serais tenté
d'ajouter que l'antisémitisme à d'autres
sources que l'anti-judaïsme qu'ils se
sont mutuellement contaminé
affreusement rendu service
si bien que on peut espérer tout de même
que l'anti-judaïsme disparaissant
l'antisémitisme pourrait perdre lui une
de ses forces vives fut-elle
inconsciente se mêlent pour elle est
chez les incroyants si vous le permettez
monsieur nous allons faire une pause je
puis dire nous allons nous tourner vers
svp au guide arbois nous attend avec de
très nombreuses questions des
manquements et oui et je voudrais
d'abord demandé aux téléspectateurs
qu'ils essaient de nous joindre de bien
vouloir patienter effectivement le
standard est embouteillée mais je viens
de procéder à une première analyse des
questions qui sont sur mon bureau et on
voit déjà se dessiner quelques grands
thèmes qui sont le rôle de l'église dans
sémitisme beaucoup téléspectateurs nous
demande de parler de l'antisémitisme
derrière le rideau de fer de notre
problème est celui de l'être simulation
il ya également des reproches précis que
des téléspectateurs font aux juifs et je
voudrais commencer par celle ci il y à
de très très nombreuses questions que
l'on peut résumer ainsi
comment peut-on en quel est exactement
le texte de la loi qui protège les juifs
contre l'antisémitisme
je suis pas lent et en réalité
la france a toujours affirmé dans ces
constitutions successives
entre ces deux derniers siècles
l'égalité des citoyens
devant la loi
cependant assez paradoxalement
il n'y a rien dans la législation
française
qui constitue une répression ou une
menace de répression
desmenez racistes et antisémites
est mis à la réalisation française
qu'une seule petite chose
qu'on appelle le décret marchandeau qui
est l'article 32 je crois de la loi sur
la presse
on ne peut réprimer en fait le racisme
que sous l'angle de la diffamation qu'il
constitue et qui plus est
en ne réprime
l'excitation au racisme la
discrimination raciale que sous l'angle
de la diffamation personnel il faut
qu'il y ait préjudice personnel et
direct pour que l'on puisse poursuivre
de ce fait
nous sommes sur ce plan
infiniment moins bien placé
que par exemple la société protectrice
des animaux dont je me félicite qu'elle
obtienne aisément le franc symbolique de
dommages d'intérêts chaque fois que la
preuve est établie d'une bête a été
malmené mais il n'existe rien dans la
législation française
qui puisse assurer aux citoyens
déconsidérés pour deux raisons de race
ou de religion il n'existe rien de
semblable à ce qui est encore une fois
je me félicite de voir exister pour la
protection de nos chers bébêtes monsieur
simon - vous avez vous entends député
rappelle que vous êtes ancien ministre
du commerce extérieur vous êtes
actuellement député de la lozère et vous
avez déposé à ce titre un projet de loi
sur le bureau de l'assemblée un projet
de loi contre la discrimination raciale
oui et ça ne pour compléter sans doute
au point pour c'est justement eu des
marchands d'eau exactement pour
compléter cette fois marchande où le
problème ne concerne pas
particulièrement les juifs ce qui était
l'objet de ce soir
les films ce soir mais en fait ce projet
de loi consiste justement à permettre la
répression dans certains cas il ne faut
pas abuser bien sûr mais la répression
d'un certain nombre d'actes qui sont
commis assez régulièrement et malgré
cette fois marchandeau même quelquefois
travers la presse
ainsi nous avons vu un certain nombre de
journaux et ils le font d'une manière
plus ou moins dissimulées
citer des faits qui ont un caractère
raciste en fait notamment en ce qui
concerne les algériens qui soi-disant
sont les seuls à commettre des viols et
des rapts dans les rues de paris
et ainsi de suite en fait
la façon dont ils présentent leurs
problèmes ne permet pas bien de réprimer
comme disait justement monsieur pas lent
il s'agissait la répression est possible
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un acte diffamation
privée
etc
et c'est le but de ce projet de loi que
je ne veux pas vous raconter mais qui a
été déposée il ya quelques temps sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
le but de ce projet de loi est de
permettre à une législatrice lation de
même de faire jurisprudence
il ya toujours un autre point que je
voudrais aborder
les principaux arguments qui m'ont été
proposées lorsque j'ai déposé ce projet
de loi était les arguments
qui ont une certaine valeur je crois que
je suis un peu le baja mettre cette
assemblée et je crois qu'il est
important de le dire ce soir
c'est le sentiment de beaucoup et c'est
le mien d'ailleurs que dans les jeunes
générations
le racisme a tendance à disparaître
et c'est excellent et c'est une chose
que je voudrais dire à nos amis juifs
ici ce soir
n'est ce pas il ne faudrait pas qu'à
travers le traumatisme qu'on cause et
l'effet de la dernière guerre il ne
faudrait pas ou que les juifs exalte un
certain complexe
qui
tend les isolés qui tend à les mettre en
exergue
n'est ce pas ce film que nous avons vu
est un très mauvais film à mon avis et
je veux dire pourquoi aux états unis
il n'y a pas eu que le phénomène
antisémite
il ya eu le phénomène tout à fait normal
d'un corps qui a tendance à empêcher les
corps étrangers de pénétrer or
l'amérique a été peuplée par des
immigrations successives
il ya eu le même problème avec les
irlandais à new york il ya quelques
années on peut dire que c'est l'ère
kennedy qui les a key à annulé sept
on peut dire également que il y
actuellement le même problème bien sûr
avec les noirs puisqu'on en parle tous
les jours dans la presse mais il existe
également avec les portoricains
c'est en fait un nouvel apport
d'immigrants dont par une réaction un
peu bestial les gens qui sont qui sont
là se disent ils vont prendre un morceau
de mon gâteau n'est ce pas et c'est ça
qui est créé cette espèce de racisme de
bas étage et se filmer me verrai ce
point de vue là parce que comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure ce marchand
jackman cézac ma
famille m'a dit tu as l'air il traite
d'un racisme de peau et ce n'est pas le
fond du problème
néanmoins ce racisme de pau existe en
france et que lorsque je dis que les
juifs ne doit pas se mettre en exergue
l'antisémitisme pour moi est quelque
chose de plus large car on peut dire que
les arabes aussi sont sémites
n'existe pas de la cmuc on considère
qu'il existe une liste méditerranéenne
mais c'est pas d'accord vous me disais
tout à l'heure qu'il y avait une tribu
en angleterre qui se croyait être la
seule à les convictions subjectif c'est
une autre question et tout le malheur il
ya des corrections subjective
je partage tout à fait l'un l'opinion de
monsieur de chambrun sur le film je
crois qu'effectivement ce n'est pas un
très bon film ce que je connais
personnellement de l'amérique me montre
comme avoue enfin des des couches
différentes de population qui se
chevauchent qui ne se mêle pas et tout
se situe à l'intérieur deux communautés
mais ce que je voudrais dire touche à
l'antisémitisme c'est que je ne voudrais
pas que l'on confond dit
antisémitisme et haine du juif
ni haine des juifs ni haine du juif
l'antisémitisme n'est pas à l'heure
actuelle essentiellement une haine des
juifs elle est une manière dont
les hommes utilisent un terme vidé de
toute substance pour 6 décharger de
leurs propres complexes l'air ce qui la
hisse soi-même eux même si un monsieur
se trouve en état d'infériorité ghanim
al sa vie etc c'est naturellement à
cause des juifs qui ne gagnent bien leur
vie si un monsieur se trouve dans une
situation pénible sur le plan matériel
sur le plan physique ou autre
immédiatement ils se déchargent de cette
manière bref il s'agit ici d'un complexe
psychanalytique que d'ailleurs léon
poliakov a fort bien admirablement
analysé dans son dernier bouquin et qui
me paraît beaucoup plus redoutable à
l'heure actuelle qu'une haine ouverte je
retrouve ce que nous visions tout à
l'heure d'autres questions svp oui les
téléspectateurs demande que l'on parle
de l'antisémitisme en union soviétique
et derrière le rideau très
et les visées vous avez écrit de
nombreux livres sur les juifs mais
notamment un ouvrage qui s'appelle les
juifs du silence et qui est consacré
justement aux juifs l'union soviétique
j'ai écouté pendant une heure cette
discussion là j'étais un peu effaré je
crois qu'on va pas toucher à l'essentiel
l'essentiel
c'est d'abord non seulement la cause et
la conséquence
il ya des gens qui parlent et on oublie
que les mots c'est chose de très
dangereux c'est très très dangereux
lemos la dynamite de la mort pendant
d'un siècle ont parlé en évoquant un tas
de motifs et ça a donné quoi ça a donné
une fin d'une civilisation qui s'appelle
ensuite et cette ombre et là vous
allaitez allusion aux chutes et c'est
dans ce contexte là que j'aimerais vous
dire à vous monsieur le député
je crois
que lorsque l'on est à un écrivain
ou intellectuels en général
lorsqu'il parle lorsqu'il écrit
lorsqu'ils s'expriment il n'est pas
seulement responsable ce qu'il dit mais
aussi de la manière dont cela est
interprété
si par exemple
excusez moi mais faut que je le dise
parce que je laisse eu le coeur si par
exemple général de go que je ne crois
pas antisémite avait 10 novembre dernier
en parlant du peuple vive disant qu'ils
sont peut-être dominateurs depuis même
tournée de la conquête et la domination
etc je sais enfin j'espère pour lui
parce que je pense en terme d'histoire
en catégorie d'histoire pour de gaulle
et j'aimerais qu'il reste dans
l'histoire ce personnage que nous
amenions l'homme de 18 juin mais nous
savons aussi que ces paroles ont
malheureusement était interprétée par
les antisémites comme xavier vallat par
exemple qui réjouissent et là c'est une
responsabilité très lourde
lorsque vous même monsieur le député
vous dit ce soir que les juifs devraient
lentement un peu plus rapidement
peut-être se débarrasser de ce complexe
complexe de souffrance voulez-vous dire
n'est ce pas complexe du martyr voulez
vous dire en d'autres termes n'est pas
par les temps du passé en d'autres
termes ne pas invoquer offrir non que
moi même je n'aime pas invoquer je crois
que vous avez tort
parce que hélas c'est ma profonde
conviction et je le vois presque tous
les jours dans les journaux en ouvrant
et jude law que tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le monde de relier à
cet événement central
intense et irrationnel qui s'appelle
auschwitz si aujourd'hui il ya une telle
indifférence dans le monde à l'égard de
bien fera par exemple
ou même à l'égard de ce qui se passe en
tchécoslovaquie se relier encore au fait
concentrationnaire je crois que
l'indifférence aujourd'hui dans le monde
n'est même plus un péché c'est déjà une
punition en soit
je crois que n'avons pas le droit
d'oublier ça parce que
le monde le père à l'humanité le p déjà
je crois que fritz a engendré hiroshima
cela que la conception du génocide ou de
l'amour total a été inventé donnez nous
étions le premier les autres les
prochains ne le seront plus
en d'autres termes soyons prudents avec
les mots
ou bien vous répondre sur trois points
d'abord vous avez mentionné les paroles
prononcées par le général de gaulle si
je me souviens bien qu'ils étaient être
que le peuple juif étaient un peuple
fier et dominateur mais pour des gens
qui connaissent le général de gaulle
j'ai pensé toujours que c'était un
compliment car quiconque est un homme
d'état de sa stature est fier et
dominateur
professeur jérôme convient d'évoquer à
la fois le cas du général de gaulle et
le cas de l'antisémitisme en russie je
ne veux pas identifié l'un à l'autre
bien sûr mais il ya un fait c'est que
depuis une vingtaine de siècle et mon
voisin tout à l'heure viennent le
confirmer on a entretenu un certain anti
judaïsme qui peut parfaitement être
acceptée et qui dans l'esprit populaire
a été trop souvent identiques fier à
l'antisémitisme et le résultat c'est que
toutes les fois que aujourd'hui on parle
d'un juif comme d'un élément différent
on travaille dans une atmosphère déjà
favorable
parce que
ataviquement des millions des dizaines
de millions de chrétiens ont été à tort
ou à raison
élevé dans cette idée que les juifs a
une certaine responsabilité dans la mort
du christ et par conséquent dans un pays
chrétien
le retentissement
d'une phrase qui pour d'autres des
agnostiques ou des bouddhistes
paraîtrait sans doute beaucoup moins
grave ça prend un volume ça prend une
ampleur et le résultat c'est que dix
phrases anodines
immédiatement fond m hornet plus
exactement dans la population des
sentiments qu'ils étaient profondément
ancrée qui jusque là ne s'était pas
exprimé car il est assez curieux de voir
en france que le les gens souvent ne
sont pas fondamentalement anti sémite
mais comme dans le film que nous venons
de voir dès que le problème
se pose un problème pour eux un problème
individuel et bien il ya une grosse
urgence de cet antisémitisme et je pense
que le problème et doit être à peu près
la même chose en russie
lorsqu'on évoque le juif en russie comme
quand lorsqu'on évoque le juif en pays
catholique comme la france il ya un
certain concept qui fait qu'il ya une
réaction qui est infiniment plus brutale
qu'elle ne le serait dans une autre
atmosphère
je sais d'ailleurs que les jce
catholique fait ce qu'elle peut pour
modifier cette orientation
mais on ne rattrape pas en 20 semaines
ce qui s'est fait en vingt siècles si
vous le permettez je sais bien que vous
voudriez tous complété ce que vient de
dire le professeur giro mais je voudrais
prendre d'autres questions car il ya
beaucoup téléspectateurs qui nous ont
appelés ils attendent voudrait bien être
satisfait quitte à revoir eh bien on
peut résumer certaines réactions des
téléspectateurs de cette façon ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il ya un problème
juif à cause justement des eux-mêmes qui
s'enferment dans certaines castes de la
société et ça pose le problème de la
simulation
je suis là bas les al ghad je dois dire
tout d'abord n'est ce pas je n'ai pas
pris la parole jusqu'à présent d'abord
ça aurait été difficile parce que tout
le monde envie de parler et ensuite
parce que nous tous ont des problèmes
tellement complexe et délicat que je
crois qu'en tout cas je représentais ce
soir sinon les juifs en tout cas tous
les soutes et les 8 et en lisant que je
prouve un sentiment de frustration suis
certain que les téléspectateurs devant
leur écran on envie de dire à chacun
nous oui mais parce que chacune des
choses qui ont été affirmés ce soir et
contre vers siel et je ne puis donc dire
sur ce point mais pour réponse à la
question de ce téléspectateur que ce qui
me paraît important en définitive dans
l'existence de l'anti sémitisme
non point les causes que l'on peut
continuer à analyser très longuement
monsieur poliakov analysé pendant de
longues années je veux dire que
j'approuve beaucoup j'admire monsieur
polyakov je le plains parce que pendant
20 ans avoir lu des textes et textes
antisémites ramassés pendant 2000 ans
d'histoire je trouve que c'est pas un
métier très drôle on peut dire qu'il ya
des causes religieuses elles sont
profondes et existiez déco économie
elle repose sur toutes sortes de
généralisations hâtives et la question
posée par ce téléspectateur en est une
il me semble que là n'est pas le
problème le problème fondamental se
passer le froid de la différence et
c'est justement la question qui vient
d'être posée et il nous sommes une
équivoque quand on parle d'
antisémitisme parce que d'une part vous
avez des juifs qu'ils disent mais enfin
pourquoi est antisémite puisque nous
sommes absolument comme tout le monde et
puis d'autre part vous avez des juifs
qui disent nous ne sommes pas comme tout
le monde mais c'est pas une raison pour
être antisémite je voulais dire mon cher
alain jérôme personnellement toujours
été très éloignés de ce problème je
comprends pas qu'on prend pas le
problème d'antisémitisme j'en ai très
peu souffert j'ai la chance de vivre
dans un pays qui a je crois des
traditions libérales quand même assez
profondément enraciné la chance d'avoir
beaucoup d'amis chrétien ou marxiste et
athée et je n'ai pas souffert de ce
problème mais
je suis de ceux qui veulent rester juive
représente effectivement temps carabins
des juifs qui pensent qu'ils ont à
maintenir une certaine fidélité une
certaine tradition et qui vraiment je
crois de moins en moins comprennent
pourquoi on leur tient rigueur de la
fidélité je crois que là il ya quelque
chose de très fondamental dans
l'antisémitisme qui est une maladie sur
de tuberculose de l'humanité contre
laquelle on peut inoculé le bcg mais on
se rend compte à longue échéance qu'il
faut beaucoup beaucoup de rappel parce
qu'elle est si profondément enraciné
temps dans le l'organisme humain que
cette maladie ne peut pas se garer
facilement eh bien je dirais que
nous ne comprenons pas parce que nous
estimons que chacun le droit c'est
différent c'est qu'ils se trouvent alors
choses assez extraordinaire que pour moi
à l'antisémitisme apparaît comme une
sorte de lunettes il ya 2000 ans on a
posé des lunettes sur sur le nez des
hommes et depuis ce temps là à travers
ses lunettes il voit les j80 au son des
lunettes de soleil tantôt selon lui l'ue
et du coup leur en fait ils les voient
comme ils veulent le voir léon poliakov
a montré aux marinas c'était le diable
aujourd'hui c'est des accapareurs il ya
des dominateurs demain que 16 jeux
d'hier est d'ailleurs fort peut-être un
peu plaisamment qu' il ya sûrement des
progrès dans ce domaine puisque je vous
disais tout à l'heure et à chaque
dimanche des millions de français qui
perd de l'argent tiercé et j'ai encore
vu aucun journal en accuser les justes
qui prouve tout de même et dans cette
notion de bouc émissaire et bien le
blues juif n'est plus le bouc émissaire
et les recettes mais il y à des juifs
qu'ils entendent rester fidèle et je le
disais ça peut paraître le grand
paradoxe de l'antisémitisme l'antisémite
n'est pas un juif qui reprend celui ce
qu'il est mais qui invente un juif pour
pouvoir lui reprocher un certain nombre
de choses parfois ses propres échecs ses
propres frustrations de telle sorte que
le premier combat de nos fossés on porte
des lunettes déformantes le juif on lui
reproche des choses qui ne seraient pas
reprocher à quelqu'un d'autre ses vertus
deviennent des défauts la fidélité c'est
de l'obstination et la solidarité dont
les juifs sont solidaires c'est vrai et
alors je souhaiterais que tous les
hommes sont solidaires et lorsque
d'autres peuples solidaires parce que
d'autres sociétés d'autres groupes
humains sont solidaires entre eux c'est
merveilleux légis solidaire quand des
juifs souffre larcker commence à battre
il ne bat pas seulement pour les juifs
qui souffrent plus vous montrer en
beaucoup de circonstances alors la
solidarité devient que sais-je
l'international juive et cetera et
cetera je crois que c'est ça le problème
le problème est celui à mon sens
uniquement à ce point de vue que
l'antisémitisme intéresse
personnellement le problème d'une
humanité qui n'a pas su résoudre ces
problèmes et dont le judaïsme je crois
enfin l'histoire des juifs l'existence
des juifs l'existence de l'antisémitisme
c'est le texte très précis de son état
de santé alors des gens comme elie
wiesel qui pour moi est une sorte de
statut de commandeur l'antisémitisme qui
représente pour moi 6 millions d'êtres
humains présents dans ce studio est bien
il nous a semblé à nous juifs qu au
moment de la guerre voilà la grande
famille humaine avait sacrifié sur
l'autel de l'antisémitisme c'est à dire
le refus de la différence elle avait
sacrifié un enfant et deux enfants qu 6
millions d'enfants qui sont ceux tout le
monde et pas seulement sur 18 et nous
sommes que dans une famille quand unis à
une fièvre qui a un enfant qui meurt un
deuxième un troisième sommes qu'à la fin
les parents surveillent un peu leur
thermomètre et lorsque prochain enfants
à la ferme ils font attention et puis on
constate que nous c'est pas le problème
d'antisémitisme ne m'inquiète pas ni
pour moi ni pour ma famille pour mes
enfants ni pour les juifs parce qu'il ya
12 millions de musulmans mais à trois
milliards d'êtres humains et c'est
pourquoi je termine sur ce point le
problème des jus de l'est est important
parce que nous constatons une chose
chaque fois que il y à une chute de la
démocratie chaque fois qu'un régime
devient plus totalité aux premiers sont
visés sont dénoncées même lorsqu'il
n'existe pas les juifs là le bouc
émissaire continuer à exister et ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en pologne et en
tchécoslovaquie en russie est
extrêmement net lorsqu'un régime tend à
devenir totalitaire il accuse les juifs
sans démocratie et bien qu'il n'y a pas
de possibilité de cessation
d'antisémitisme mais tant qu'existe
d'antisémitisme j'ai bien peur qu'il n'y
ait pas de véritable démocratie voilà si
vous voulez mon sentiment et voilà
pourquoi nous voulons continuer à rester
juste parce que nous pensons que nous
sommes à beaucoup de points de vue
exactement comme tout le monde et nous
en sommes heureux et que d'autres points
de vue grâce à une certaine expérience
nous allons peut-être conservé au plus
profond de notre conscience un certain
nombre de petites phrases du tas minutes
qui volent dans les oeuvres d'elie
wiesel et parfois dans nos rêves comme
d'être plutôt des persécutés que des
persécuteurs fond si tous les chefs
d'états penser ça soit qu'elles
choisiraient un peu mieux sur la planète
ensuite chambre à vous souhaitez oui
j'aurais dire brièvement une chose c'est
que pour beaucoup qui sont
qui lutte contre tous les phénomènes de
racisme nous estimons que la seule
solution
est l'intégration sociale est le seul
pays qui a commencé à pratiquer seul
véritablement et le brésil et je
voudrais pour souligner mon propos vous
raconter une anecdote on sera tous
kim a été
dense était bénéficiaire
c'était un rabbin juif originaire de
pologne qui avaient eu la bonne fortune
de pouvoir atteindre le brésil
et qui donc exercer son ministère là bas
et en parlant un soir avec lui mais
comment aimez-vous le brésil et il m'a
dit en riant c'est curieux et dans ce
pays j'en oublie presque être juif mais
ça me permettez je crois qu'il faut
détruire absolument ce mythe parce qu'il
ya là un préjugé c'était terrible
peut-être le plus dangereux de
l'antisémitisme n'est pas celui qui
consiste à penser que
pour mettre fin à l'antisémitisme il n'y
a qu'une solution finale finale
finalement ou bien on les brûle ou bien
on fait qu'il n'ya plus de juifs en
faisant qu'il cesse d'être juif non non
je veux dire qu'il fait qu'il cesse
d'être revu pourquoi
j'entends bien venez on peut lire que
vous l'a dit ce que d'autres l'ont dit
il n'y a pas de race juive le premier
pennetta gars sont à ce point de savoir
si un groupe a le droit de conserver ses
habitudes de pensée sa culture sa
civilisation sans constituer pour autant
une agression pour l'humanité pour moi
les minorités ne constituent pas des
régressions et je crois qu'il ya quelque
chose d'essentiel dans cela tous les
jours dans mon travail je rencontre des
amis non juifs je dois vous dire que le
fait qu'il soit non juifs me passionne
parce qu en les rencontrant j'ai quelque
chose de leur apporter d'abord il faut
que j'explique pourquoi je suis venu
faut que je me justifie il faut
peut-être que ça me donne des devoirs
particuliers à leur égard et ensuite je
suis je suis intrigué parce que j'ai en
face de moi des êtres qui sont
différents et j'ai même passion de
savoir pourquoi eux aussi sont
différents et ce qu'ils ont à ma portée
et si par malheur à eux et moi nous
n'étions ni juif ni chrétien ni quoi que
ce soit au lieu de chercher à les aimer
allez comprendre je chercherai à les
singes et c'est pourquoi je suis pas
pour la simulation
[Musique]
d'abord je dois une réponse que j'ai
tout à l'heure au sujet des foules
avaient retardé un petit peu oui au
sujet des juifs en bourse il ya trois
millions de vies en sûrs ce là le
problème très simple tous
obligatoirement consulté d'identité de
non juifs ce qui comporte un tas de
primates
discriminations sociales économiques
culturelles etc
on a vu que dernièrement il a été
confirmé par la presse que lorsque
francis eck clients
le leader tchèque est arrivé avec deux
chèques à moscou drège 9 le traité de
sale galicien juif donc ça vous donne le
ton
ce qui est encore pire est là parce que
c'est délirant c'est la pologne où il ya
onze mille juifs aux mille là où il y
avait jadis 3 millions de juifs tous
tués en pologne
et là il ya encore un antisémitisme et
là je crois que poliakov sera d'accord
avec max le phénomène sans précédent
l'antisémitisme sans juifs
cela dit
à l'afp
c'est à dire
moi je n'aime pas
être acculé au choix j'aime pas ce choix
que je dois me définir soi en tant que
juif soit en tant qu'être humain mais
qui vous dont le droit de juger kivu
dont le droit de dire que juif n'est pas
un être humain membre de la société
comme tous les autres au contraire moi
je crois que juif ne peut ne peut
accéder à ce niveau total d'être humain
autrement que par son judaïsme de même
qu'un catholique par son catholicisme un
bouddhiste par son bouddhisme enfin il
faut être ce que nous sommes si honni ce
droit je crois que on cesse d'être
humains et l'agent chêneraie et je
dirais que je sais que cet argument a
été avancée
c'est en fait par un tas de juifs que
nous appelons chez nous des juifs
honteux
il ya des juifs qui n'aiment pas être
juif qui se cache qui change de nom qui
change de religion j'en connais
ces juifs là
croyez-le ne font pitié n'ont pas honte
pitié parce que pour moi qui vit à
l'intérieur du judaïsme parce que j'ai
été le des danses forcément dans cette
religion de cette tradition la maquiller
cei d'assumer ce passé
avec tout ce que ça comporte
moi je trouve que en tant que je lui
c'est une aventure extrêmement belle que
pour eux vivent aujourd'hui survivants
parce que chaque juif dans le droit
d'être appelé survivants pour rire c'est
un privilège que de participer à ce soir
car c'est ainsi qu'il participe à
l'histoire et à l'oeuvre de l'humanité
tout entière ce que je vous donne moi
monsieur l'abbé si vous voulez c'est
l'image de mon judaïsme ce que je vous
demande vous ce l'image de votre
christianisme ce que je vous demande à
vous monsieur le député se l'image de
votre humanité du politicien que vous
êtes en d'autres termes réalisez-vous
entièrement totalement sans vous daignez
et sans son meunier mois le droit d'être
ce que je suis
cc de m'opposer à vous cessez de
m'opposer au monde cesser d'opposer le
juif que je suis aux hommes qui ne sont
pas
[Musique]
nombreux nous allons terminer cette
émission vous vous répondre on se disait
n'est ce pas vous qui cherchez à vous
opposer je crois que jusqu'en être le
traumatisme que vous avez pu souffrir en
vous même mais à travers le judaïsme
mais ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est que je crois être le
benjamin de cette assemblée et et ans le
benjamin oublier le politicien je vous
dis tout simplement qu'un certain nombre
d'entre nous pensons que la solution de
ces problèmes est véritablement une
intégration raciale c'est simple ce que
nous pensons enfin enceinte allons de
nouveau l'intégration sociale c'est à
dire véritablement le brassage ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure nous avons
chacun 10 millions d'ancêtres donc nous
devrons probablement tous du sang j'ai
déjà fait de ses origines
il nous aura terminé avec vous c'est que
le lendemain problème de l'antisémitisme
c'est le problème de l'égalité des
droits c'est tout simplement problème
des droits de l'homme et vous le savez
nous avons appris à 2 heures il est un
des plus éminents juives de france qui a
été le rédacteur de la loi réclame à ce
universelle des droits de l'homme et qui
aujourd'hui a reçu le prix nobel de la
paix ne serait ce que ça ça justifie
peut-être le fait qu'ils aient des juifs
qui a voulu rester chez le droit à la
différence je vous remercie monsieur
vous remercie tous d'avoir bien voulu
participer à cette émission et je vous
remercie aussi ami téléspectateurs de
nous avoir rappelé j'espère que nous
avons pu dans la mesure de nos d'une
temps qui nous est imparti répondre à
toutes vos questions et je vous donne
rendez-vous donc pour un prochain
dossier de l'écran bonsoir
[Musique]